[Music]
we all loved watching Disney movies no
matter how old we are but if you ever
read the original tells you'll find out
that they are absolutely not appropriate
for kids that's because we're not sure
whether they are reading a love story or
a horror story stay tuned until the end
to know what really happened to Rapunzel
if you love Disney as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten disturbing real
stories behind Disney fairy tales Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs we all
remember the story of Snow White the
young girl who ran away from her home
because her stepmother was jealous of
her beauty she wanted the hunter to come
back with her heart but the princess had
the chance to stay with the Seven Dwarfs
it didn't keep the Evil Queen from
trying to get rid of her one more time
and make her eat a poisoned Apple when
we think about it the Disney movie
really sounds like a horror story too
but the original story is actually worse
in the Brothers Grimm version the Evil
Queen still wanted to get rid of her
daughter but this time she wanted the
hunter to come back with her lungs and
her liver when he came back with the
body parts of a boar the cream
immediately ate them thinking they
belong to Snow White but when she heard
the truth she tried to get rid of the
princess two other times before giving
her the poisoned Apple he evil fleas
sold her bodice laces that were so tight
that she stopped her breathing and also
gave her a poisoned comb it was a
warning to teach young girls that they
shouldn't become vain at the end of the
tale the Evil Queen was punished when
she was forced to wear a burning hot
iron shoes and danced until she takes
her last breath surprisingly as
grown-ups we preferred this ending hey
guys we are so excited to announce we're
producing
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section she left me
here from you see you there
Cinderella in this story a young girl is
forced to work as a servant before her
fairy godmother gives her the chance to
go to the ball where she meets her
prince charming
it looks really romantic except when you
think that he didn't even recognize the
love of his life after that night but
you will find out that it's not that bad
when you hear what really happened to
Cinderella and her sisters in the
Brothers Grimm version the princess
didn't have a fairy godmother but
planted a tree by her mother's grave and
prayed under it every day this is where
she found dresses to wear to each fall
as she went to three balls in this story
the Prince only danced with her before
the mysterious princess disappeared by
jumping into a pigeon coop or climbing
up a pear tree this is why on the third
night he decided to set a trap to make
sure that she wouldn't escape the
stairway was smeared with pitch and this
is why she lost a shoe when he tried to
find who it belonged to this is when
things go a little crazy
the sisters tried it and cut off their
toes and their heels to fit in the shoes
but the prince noticed the blood when
Cinderella finally got married they
tried to attend the wedding but their
eyes were pecked out by birds this is
not what we call a happily ever after
Sleeping Beauty this story was already
weird to start with a young woman falls
asleep until she is saved by the kiss of
a prince but when you think about it it
is not romantic at all to kiss someone
without their consent but it is not that
bad when you hear about the original
story in the original tale by
Giambattista Basile a called the Sun the
moon and Talia absolutely nothing can
ever be considered romantic this time
there are no fairies but menu foretell
that the princess will be put in great
danger by a splinter of flax became
tried to protect her but on her 16th
birthday she saw an old woman spinning
on a spindle when she tried to stretch
the flax it went under her nail and she
passed away when her father found out
about this he left the body of his
daughter in his home and less
this place forever after some time
another king came to their home and his
Falcon flew into the window of his
palace he entered the place and found a
beautiful girl who couldn't wake up this
is when things get really inappropriate
he took her to bed and made love to her
let's just tell you once again that dead
girls can't consent how I became
pregnant and gave birth to twins and
it's when his son sucked on her finger
and removed the Splinter of flax that
she finally woke up that's not romantic
The Little Mermaid this Disney movie
looks really nice before you think that
Ariel gave away everything for a
stranger and changed who she was to
please him everything was fine at the
end but we still think that she took too
many risks for a man that she did know
unfortunately for the original Little
Mermaid things didn't work out for her
in Anderson's tale the story is really
similar but the toys that she makes is
worse The Little Mermaid exchanges her
tongue for a pair of legs but this time
if she fails she won't only turn back
into a mermaid she will actually die if
she fails just to make things worse she
wants to walk on earth because humans
have eternal souls while mermaids don't
it just makes her death much more
terrifying and having legs is not as
good as you think
in the original story every single step
she takes will feel like she is walking
on sharp shards of glass in the original
tale that Prince ends up marrying the
woman he thinks is the person who saved
him their mermaid has one more chance to
stay alive if she gets rid of the Prince
but she fails instead she throws herself
into the sea and turns into seafoam if
there is one thing that can make her
happier it's that she could earn a soul
after 300 years for the good thing that
she did
is this really a happy ending Beauty and
the Beast this love story was just
terrible when you think about it when
someone forces you to stay in their
castle no matter how nice they try to be
you shouldn't marry them we know that
the beast became a better man but things
like that don't happen in real life you
don't change people people change
themselves
this time the original story from
jean-marie le Prince de Beaumont is not
so far from what we saw in the to Disney
movies the young woman was named Beauty
which is actually the meaning of Belle
in French her father used to be a rich
merchant but things didn't really work
out for him and he became poor Beauty
also had many siblings including two
evil sisters once again his father ended
up being the prisoner of the Beast
because he stole a rose the bees told
him that he would let him go in exchange
for one of his daughters and he accepted
in exchange for things to give to his
family you know the rest of the story
but what is disturbing is that when
Beauty came back home her sisters were
extremely jealous of her luxurious life
this is why her sisters forced her to
stay even though she promised the Beast
that she would come back because they
wanted the monster to eat her alive
after all she is better with the Beast
than with her family Aladdin
this time we have nothing against the
main character even though Aladdin was a
thief he had a heart of gold
but we can't say the same thing about
Jafar who was trying to force Jasmine to
marry him which is not really a thing
that kids should see this time the
original story is really similar but
there is one thing that really surprised
us a line used to live in China which
makes him Chinese and not Arab we don't
know why they changed this important
detail but we have to admit we love
seeing the beauty of this country once
again the thief was recruited by a
sorcerer to steal the magic lamp but
this time he pretended to be the little
brother of Aladdin's late father when he
got the lam Aladdin even wanted to sell
it in exchange for food until you met
the genie this time it was much easier
to marry the princess as he had just
become rich and powerful to let the
Sultan's daughter fall into his arms
what is fun about this is that she used
to be called princess badr-al-budur
so we totally understand why they
changed her name to Jasmine the ending
is more violent as Aladdin gets rid of
the sorcerer and then slays his brother
disguised as a woman but at the end the
couple lives happily ever after so we
could say that it's our favorite story
for now Pocahontas you probably already
know that Pocahontas really existed but
if you were thinking about a young
princess who fell in love with John
Smith and saved his life before he has
to come back to Europe
that's because Disney has been lying to
you this
is absolutely wrong first Pocahontas was
only a nickname meaning spoiled child
and the girl's real name was Mitaka
she was actually still a kid when she
met John Smith so they were not in love
with each other even though sparks
didn't fly between them the man claimed
that the young Native American did save
his life when he was captured by palette
ins men but nothing proves that it
really happened as Smith only talks
about this years later
Motoko was also in contact with the
Europeans as an important supplier of
food and an informer for the colony
however they didn't like her in the best
way because she was taken prisoner at
age 17 and they held her hostage for
more than a year she made a deal with
another man John Rolfe who promised that
she would be released if she married him
Metallica became Rebecca Rolfe had a son
named Thomas and was forced to move to
Europe she passed away really young at
age 21 whoever says that this is a love
story is absolutely wrong and Disney
made a mistake when they decided to
change her story
Mulan here's a woman that should be a
role model this time Mulan didn't want
to be a housewife and decided to become
a warrior instead even if it meant that
she had to risk her life and pretend
that she was a man she did face danger
but at least this time Disney didn't
want us to believe that it was romantic
but did you know that the movie was
actually inspired by a legendary warrior
you can read the original story of the
Chinese tale The Ballad of Mulan then a
play was produced to show what happened
to Hua Mulan some people think that this
amazing woman really existed and this is
her story will tell you about the main
differences when we compare the tale to
the movie Mulan was actually a really
skilled warrior and didn't have to train
like the young woman that we saw in the
movie she grew up as a tomboy and her
father taught her how to fight at a
young age
Mulan didn't have to lie to her parents
about wanting to go to war and they even
supported her because it was the most
natural decision for her she was also
super confident from the start and
obviously didn't have any sidekick we
also loved that there was no big gender
reveal she just decided to share her
secret and everyone was okay with that
why can't we see a movie about the real
Millan The Princess and the Frog this
one is a classic but it still took years
before we had the chance to see the
movie and
Disney really surprised us we all
thought it was weird to kiss a frog and
we're happy to see that Tiana thought
the same thing too but what really
happened in the original tale the young
woman was not a waitress but a real
princess the most beautiful one anyone
has ever seen she liked to go into the
forest and sit on the edge of a pool
well to play with a golden ball she
dropped it in the water and a frog
offered to give it back to her as long
as she would accept him as her companion
and Playmate she said yes but broke her
promise when she came back home without
him the next day the Frog was at her
door she had to spend some time with him
even if she was disgusted by the little
creature
the princess became angry and threw him
against the wall this was when the Frog
turned into a beautiful prince who was
now her companion surprisingly he
forgave her and they came back to his
kingdom together so the girl was
actually really mean in the original
tale and there was no kiss so we
absolutely don't understand where it
comes from for once we think that Disney
really did a better job
tangled this was one of the most recent
Disney movies based on a tale that
people had the chance to read years ago
Flynn Rider is clearly one of the most
charming Prince's but isn't it weird to
think that he entered her room without
her permission and the princess decided
to leave with him anyway it was the best
decision she ever made but it's still
weird anyway the original tale comes
from the Brothers Grimm the beginning of
the story is really similar but this
time the man that saved her was actually
a prince he was seduced by her voice and
wanted to meet her
he asked for Cleanser to let down her
hair and crime he was so nice that she
quickly fell in love with him and they
got engaged on the same night she asked
him to bring a strand of silk every time
he would come to visit her so she could
weave a ladder but the sorceress found
out about it cut her hair and let
Rapunzel suck her in the wilderness she
tricked the prince he threw himself out
of the tower and poked out his eyes
blind he finally heard Rapunzel's voice
in the forest after she had given birth
to twins she saved him with her tears
and it was happily ever after in his
kingdom which is your favorite original
fairy tale don't be shy to enter in the
comment section down below we love
hearing what you think and that's it for
10 disturbing
real stories behind Disney fairy tales
for more stories like this to make sure
you watch 10 Disney princess connections
that will make your jaw drop thanks for
watching
[Music]